aujourd'hui c'est un jour un peu
particulier parce que je vais vous
parler d'un truc c'est ça c'est ce truc
là ça vous voyez ça c'est jay achi le ch
6 de panasonic et je suis en train de
filmer tout de suite donc toute cette
vidéo va être filmée au g h i c pour moi
c'est vraiment particulier pourquoi et
bien parce que j'ai adoré le g h 50 il
est sorti et la regarder ça la sacem g h
i alors on le voit c'est écrit juste là
ses planques et vous le verrez pas
forcément ça ch icg asus il est
vachement bien pourquoi pascal vraies
améliorations déjà vous avez un petit
bouton pour venir déclenché ici vous
avez plein de trucs super intéressant
mais regardez rien et nous emmène dans
un endroit où il ya un peu plus de
lumière on a le même look le même look
and feel qu'on avait avec elle j h 5 g h
4 c'était vraiment des boîtiers géniaux
et là il est plus épais alors je vais
tous vous filmer avec le g h i sauf une
petite partie que j'ai à venir filmer
avec de notre boîtier pour venir vous
montrer les détails dessus mais
aujourd'hui on se mérite est conclu on
va aller faire un tour complet honda ce
film est plein de choses je suis
aujourd'hui à rendre ni regarder ce que
raconte ce gie agissent c'est toujours
du micro 4/3 rosador des les affichage
sur l'écran qui sont vraiment cool et a
priori le truc qu'il vrai dingue c'est
l'auto focus qui normalement devrait
être complètement amélioré par rapport à
ce qu'on avait avant mais s'en va le
vérifier ensemble et ça c'est vachement
cool et on y va tout de suite
[Musique]
m
bel effet
[Musique]
est
ce que c'est un micro 4/3 oui c'est un
micro enquête car de toute façon ici
l'idée de la gamme g h chez panasonic
lumix c'est du micro 4/3 et donc le truc
qui est vachement intéressant de ce
micro 4/3 c'est que tous vos objectifs
que vous avez sur un gr 4 couchages 5
pourrait venir ici les adapter très
facilement sans aucun problème moi ici
là j'ai un objectif que j'avais déjà
c'est le leica c'est le 12 60 qui ouvre
à 2,8 suis là et qui est je trouve
extrêmement polyvalente ou que j'aime
bien et qui me plais énormément ici
c'est de retrouver l'idée de ce boîtier
plus compact assez léger que ce petit
objectif comme c'est du micro 4/3 l'un
des plus petits objectifs on est un côté
plus facile à porter mais elle est quand
même une différence avec le ch et h57 le
g6 il a gagné un peu emploi il a gagné
en poids pourquoi parce que vous avez un
ventilateur qui est là pour le refroidir
parce que vous avez un processeur qui
est plus puissant à l'intérieur que vous
détailler le poids est tous dans
quelques instants mais pour autant
l'expérience du boîtier compact avec
quasiment le même design on l'a ici avec
le g h i c'est ça c'est vachement
[Musique]
e
en fait tout le boulot qui a été fait
ici par panasonic c'est un boulot au
niveau du software ils sont vraiment
venus améliorer le logiciel or il ya des
améliorations au niveau matériel je vais
le film et je vous montrez vous allez
mercato qui sont vachement intéressant
mais des améliorations sont tous au
niveau software vous avez les nouveaux
connecte des nouveaux codecs qui vont
apporter quoi j'ai une bien meilleure
colorimétrie et en plus surtout que
j'aime bien ici c'est que je vais filmer
en flat vais filmer en vailog nativement
il n'y a pas besoin de venir acheter un
mode vailog en plus en plus c'est du
full vailog tient normalement plus
d'informations qui vont arriver ici dans
mon boitier ça c'est vachement bien
regarder la centrale film et vous avez
quoi là vous avez un petit bouton pour
venir à lancer l'enregistrement
directement juste là donc ça c'est parce
qu'on est donc la gelée j'ai un petit
voyant qui me permet de voir si je suis
en train de tourner au pas en plus d'un
point de vue se trouvait à venir à bout
des choses ici j'ai rajouté un petit
cadre rouge qui me permet de voir et
bien que je suis en train d'enregistrer
alors j'ai un petit niveau je vous ai
mis le but mettre du micro et en plus de
ça j'ai rajouté vaud d'ici là vous voyez
les petites barres juste là ça donne le
cadre en 16/9 donc à plein de petites
options qui sont vachement bien en plus
sur le dessus du boîtier voyez j'ai mon
petit bouton rouge qui va venir
enclenché ici je vous parlais de
l'épaisseur il est quand même vachement
plus épais que ce que j'avais avant avec
mon gh5 alors bénéfices c'est que je
vous dis vous avez ce grand ventilateur
avec une vraie prise d'air et puis en
plus de ça vous pouvez venir le lever
comme ça si vous voulez filmé et avoir
votre vue comme ça vous pouvez lavera
dont il ya quand même pas mal de
bénéfices donc on est un peu plus épais
monde meilleur prise d'air donc ce mal
refroidir beaucoup plus parce qu'on a
ici en plus un nouveau proche donc ça
c'est vachement cool tout petits un
travail au niveau à des boutons du
design sinon elle même look and feel
qu'on avait avec le gh5 et le même
format bien qu'il soit un peu plus
[Musique]
fred pas nice il ya vachement beau c'est
au niveau du sauveteur il ya eu deux ans
de développement software les équipes de
panasonic nous ont dit que la première
fois qu'elles ont vu ce boîtier physique
c'était en 2020 et voyez on est en 2022
il y arrive il va sortir et a donc fallu
beaucoup de temps pour point de vue
logiciel pour que panahi arrive enfin et
qu'enfin surtout on est quelque chose
qui soit extrêmement complet ce gros
boulot sauf quand je vous dis une fois
de plus la reconnaissance des visages je
le vois sur un pré tracking au niveau de
mon visage l'impression qu'elle la
netteté partout où c'était le gros point
négatif du ga chaque mois je l'adoré jai
ainsi filmé pendant des heures avec
c'est le début j'ai commencé d'ailleurs
machettes ou des bustes un os mobile et
puis je me suis rapidement rendu compte
qu'il me fallait un boîtier et le g15
s'est imposée extrêmement rapidement
mais il avait vraiment des limites au
niveau du tracking c'est pour ça que
j'ai passée après chez saunier qu'un ac
tech 3 qui mâche mans bien en termes de
compacité je vais quand même venir
préféré c'est ce que propose lumix c'est
plus petits un peu plus compact un poil
plus léger pour le studio j'adore la ca
t3 mais je me dis que vous voyez en mode
bloc pour venir me balader gh5 me
manquer quand même beaucoup mais il
manquait toujours ce côté là où on des
fois on se dit est ce que je suis une
espèce que je suis pas net c'est des
fois un peu la surprise parce qu'on
venait des rochers là en tout cas le
travail qui est fait c'est ça y est j'ai
l'impression qu'à enfin panasonic a
réussi que vous propose un truc qui va
vraiment venir suivre votre visage ya
plusieurs options au niveau logiciel je
vais vous montrer aussi le menu très
rapidement pour vous voyez ce qu'on vous
propose et une fois de plus c'est gros
boulot software qu'il faut venir retenir
ici et ça c'est vachement cool alors je
vous disais qu effectivement il ya eu
aussi ce fameux vailog on avait levé log
avant sauf que là ici on est dans un
full belloc comme dans un plat format
sauf qu'ici c'est du micro 4/3 c'est pas
un log light comme on avait sur du gh5
vous pouvez également avoir à l'aperçu
avec des notes directement sur votre
petit cadran l'a directement sur un
moniteur si vous le souhaitez mais ça
c'est pas tout nouveau et puis truc est
vachement intéressant aussi c'est que
vous avez un enregistrement illimitée
tant que vous pouvoir mettre dans votre
carte vous à les enregistrer et la carte
on en parle aussi tout à l'heure parce
que vous allez voir que c'est une très
jolie nouveauté que nous à résorber
panasonic et enthousiaste
[Musique]
en profite pour s'installer en même
temps de ce boîtier est ici on filme en
4 2 2 10 bits on peut se faire plein
plein de choses toujours les j'ai
toujours pratiqué moi je vous ai vu il
ya plusieurs niveaux de stabilisation
moi j'ai poussé la star la plus forte
histoire pouvoir tenir à la main de
marché d'être sûr que ça bouge pas que
ça c'est le point qui est extrêmement
fort et qui est vraiment intéressant si
vous voulez de la super stabilité vous
avez un truc est génial et là j'ai
l'impression que vraiment mais c'est un
truc qui m'intéresse vraiment c'est le
faux cul je me sens que le focus is
c'est vachement bien alors par contre si
j'ai pas un ultra grand angle qui fait
que la voyez j'ai le bras tendu mais ça
me dérange pas je retrouve mes repères
par rapport à ce que j'avais osé h 5 ça
marche vraiment bien je peux régler mon
expo là je suis qu allah je suis avec 9
9 9 et 9 voir ça va ça va ça marche
vraiment hyper bien une fois de plus en
cette bête ce que je vais dire mais le
fait qu'ils aient vraiment fait évoluer
sa d'un point de vue logiciel je trouve
ça vachement bien quoi vraiment vraiment
vraiment toutes ces nouveautés qu'on a
sur le boîtier de tous les côtés ça pour
moi c'est vachement bien est vraiment
vraiment bien un autre truc intéressant
c'est combien de nouveaux processeurs
c'est le venus engine nouvelle
génération nouveau processeur qui
forcément va chauffer davantage c'est
pour ça qu'ils nous ont mis un petit
ventilateur à l'arrière et qui va
augmenter la taille du boîtier mais ce
nouveau processeur permettra d'avoir
effectivement plus de calculs et d'aller
plus loin au niveau du traitement de
l'image ils ont des nouveaux codecs bref
sa tartine au max et ça c'est vachement
intéressant est le truc intéressant en
plus ici c'est qu'on a un nouveau
capteur on est sur du 25 méga pixels
sans filtre passe-bas est-ce que
panasonic nous annonce ici c'est un
boîtier qui va être deux fois plus
rapide que gh5 et surtout avec une
réduction de bruit plus plus plus alors
là le bruit en a beaucoup parce qu'on
est à la route on se parle de réduction
brute bien évidemment ici ça va donc
être bien meilleur pour tous qui va être
vidéo de nuit on va se faire tout petit
shoot lorsqu'on aura mal lumière et on a
envie vous allez voir ça va être super
intéressant et avec une plage dynamique
boostec mois ce qui est vraiment
m'intéresser c'est toute la partie vidéo
mais vous avez aussi tout un travail qui
a été fait notamment un mode rafale vous
allez shooter pas moins de 75 images en
une seconde ça c'est réellement énorme
et quand je vous parle de 75 images par
115 image en raw et autres nouveautés
significatives
vous avez ici une nouvelle carte avant
vous aviez double carte sd ici vous avez
toujours une carte sd de préserver
surtout vous avez l'arrivée de la carte
cf express qu on mettra d'avoir un
transfert beaucoup plus rapide ils nous
annoncent alors je voulais noter la cdu
5,7 qu'à 60 p 10 bits et vous pouvez
même en plus venir enregistrer en
interne et en externe en interne
directement sur votre carte et en
externe si vous le souhaitez on a
également du slow motion on peut venir
faire de la 4k 10 bits on combien 120
images par seconde et du full hd 300
images par seconde en dit également mais
également de l'anah morphx mais voilà
namor fiq je ne l'utilisent pas
peut-être un jour je le ferais peña lou
ye on a vraiment une augmentation mais
repoussé un peu limite mais c'est pas
réellement tous les usages dont on a
besoin de moi ce dont j'ai besoin ici
c'est de quatre cas ce que j'ai besoin
moi personnellement c'est une vraie
belle stabilisation ce que j'ai besoin
moi c'est d'un boîtier léger compact que
je peux emmener facilement prendre à la
main regardaient comme ça d'un côté de
l'autre sans que ça pose de problème est
là de ce que je vois au niveau de la
stabilisation ça vachement bien et
surtout avec un tracking au niveau du
visage qui doit être juste très très bon
et pas comme ce qu'on avait avant chez
pana est là pour coup en tout cas j'ai
l'impression qu'ils ont et je trouve ça
bien en tout cas c'est vraiment ce que
j'attendais comme nouveauté et on voit
vraiment que panasonic est venu écouter
ici les demandes de ses utilisateurs ils
ont pris le temps sont vraiment pris du
temps pour le sortir de ce schéma 6 mais
là le travail qui a été fourni en tout
cas de ce que je vois c'est vraiment les
premiers tests pour l'instant c'est
vraiment la découverte 1 mais je devrai
avant ce boîtier peut être plus tard un
peu plus longtemps vous vraiment prendre
le temps de l'apprivoiser mais là les
premiers tests qu'est ce qui montre que
c'est vachement bien c'est très cool et
je suis très heureux de retrouver une
sensation panasonic comme ça directement
la membrane enveloppant la rue que voilà
très chouette continue les tests
[Musique]
une
kaeppelin de belles nouveautés ici et
notamment le fait d'avoir de l'apple
prores en interne en
5,7 oui absolument en 4 2 2 et 4 de hq
it's you voulez quoi heitz q-west q je
vais vous dire hq et en termes de
qualité là je peux vous raconter que ça
va envoyer des tartines ça va aller
hyper bien pour lesdites inc ça va être
top on pourra faire plein de choses en
face et l'idée de toutes façons de ce
boîtier d'accès de se dire que en termes
d'édition on aura plus de choses au
niveau des couleurs pour pour aller plus
loin au niveau des images au niveau des
contrastes au niveau de ce qu'on va
venir capter avec ce capteur là avec
tout le travail qu'ils ont fait derrière
au niveau logiciel parce que c'est
vraiment l'idée de panasonic ici c'est
devenir aller plus loin c'est vrai que
je trouve que le g h 5 allez y à quoi il
ya deux ans peut-être un peu plus j'ai
vraiment fait des passes et que ça reste
un super boîtier un boîtier mythique moi
j'utilise pour mes top shot mais à
utiliser comme ça en boîtier principal
commençait vraiment à vieillir il
fallait qu'un jaj 6 arrive hélas
panasonic a vraiment pris les choses du
bon côté alors il est évident que si
vous voulez filmé en apple prores
varient d'un moment ça va venir afin des
fichiers un peu plus lourd où ça va être
un peu plus volumineux mais ça pourrait
le faire grâce au nouveau processeur
grâce au foehn enregistré sur une carte
cf express en plus ici les lettres sont
compatibles point cube c'est ib e ben
oui et en audio on va en 48 kg et hertz
en 24 bits en interne et en externe
alors je vous passe entre le côté un peu
trop hyper technique parce que c'est pas
réellement c'est à dire m'intéressait
moi ici moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est la
praticité c'est une fois de plus le fait
d'avoir un vrai autofocus ça croyez moi
c'est pas rien et si vous voulez vous
mêmes 4,4 canal c'est à dire qu'on peut
enregistrer par exemple avec 2 micros
laval y est pour
moi pour en intervenant à côté puis
utiliser un micro canon pour avoir un
son ambiant et puis encore pourquoi pas
un autre micro dont quatre canaux
différents donc ça c'est vachement cool
et en termes de batterie vous pouvez
utiliser la batterie du ze5 si vous le
voulez mais c'est pas celle là qui ira
le plus loin parce que ou même celle du
s5 1 vous aurez des fonctions - ce qu'il
faut vraiment utilisé c'est la batterie
qui est dédié directement à votre chat
si ce qui fonctionnera le mieux qui vous
en viendrez plus loin d'ailleurs là je
vois je tourne depuis ce matin il me
reste un peu plus de la moitié au niveau
de ma batterie franchement elle a de la
gueule entre vraiment l'idée a du g15
ici regardez je le couple c'est
exactement ce que je voulais venir vous
montrer c'est le fait d'avoir ici
regardez up votre carte cf express la
justice'' votre carte sd qui va se
planquer juste là donc ça c'est
vachement cool d'avoir cette carte cf
express hop je la remets dans histoires
de le fait d'avoir cet écran qui va
venir pivoter ça c'est vachement bien
également histoire de vous montrer un
petit peu les paramètres et très
rapidement on va retrouver l'idée ce
qu'on avait avant avec le gh5 on peut
venir ajouté plein de jauge les spots
mettre le contour de caves si vous
voulez enfin bref il ya pas mal de
petites choses qu'on peut venir faire si
je veux venir regarder donc moi je filme
en vélo gh - là je suis en train de
filmer en 4k 10 bits 50 images par
seconde pour choisir votre forme alors
match sur mp 4 ou si je m regardez en
apple prores je me mets en apple prores
effectivement ils font un pc qui
tartinent derrière et là je vais pouvoir
monter en 5,7 qu'à 25 images par seconde
quête de deux échelons voyez alors c'est
pas nécessairement ceux dont moi je vais
avoir besoin et si vous voulez vous
mettre en point moov up de la même
manière vous pouvez monter alors
attendez je vous le montre espoirs de
tout vous montrer on va monter regarder
ans et 4 + 105,8 k58 ya 4 images par
seconde en quête de zéro donc voyez
alors c'est pas le ce que je fais moi je
fais du web donc j'ai pas tous ses
besoins mais en termes de résolution
vous avez vraiment déjà tout ce qu'il
faut personnellement je me mettre comme
ça ça vient compressé mais il faut être
plus je fais du web donc il faut vivre
avec ses besoins et comme je suis là je
suis déjà pas trop mal alors après je
vais vous passer très rapidement parce
que je vais pas vous faire un tuto pour
vous montrer réellement mais on a plein
d'options je trouve qu'en terme de
software et se propose des choses sont
vachement bien par rapport à ce qu'on
avait avant on va retrouver toujours ces
petits boutons alors sur le dessus la
regarde et vous offre votre bouton pour
venir lancer l'enregistrement votre
balance des blancs votre iso régler les
expos est la même la gardie vous avez
alors attendez je vais sortir de ce mode
là si je suis comme ça par exemple venir
ajouté j'appuie sans mon petit bouton et
là je vais récupérer tout de suite mon
petit vu m et mes infos audio c'est un
truc tout bête regardez là j'ai ce petit
bouton kerala hop là j'appuie je ressors
j'appuie je reviens su donc que c'est un
truc tout bête hein mais je trouve
qu'ils ont pensé rajouter vachement de
fonctions qui sont vachement bien et
très intuitif donc ça c'est vachement
bien ce qui nous a fait pas la saône et
classieux et il ya un autre truc qu'ils
ont faits qui est bien c'est que là le
grip que vous allez retrouver ici il est
inspiré du s1 donc meilleur grip
meilleure prise en main est très très
belle finition avec votre usb c'est ici
vous allez pouvoir unir leurs charges et
et ça c'est plutôt cool donc lorsque
vous le pensez par exemple à que le hdmi
bien avec lui et ce pc vous venez de
charge et ça c'est bien bien bien gg du
hdmi 2.1 donc là vous avez une sortie 4k
à 120 images par seconde et la regardait
au petit prise jack pour votre casque là
mon petit micro qui vient se connecter
la caisse que je vous aurais pas encore
montré ça je voulais montrer tout à
l'heure on a fait le tour voile à la
batterie sur le dessous on a fait tout
après on retrouve un peu les codes de ce
qu'on avait avec le gh5 donc
très chouette comme ça me donne en tout
cas j'adore vraiment vraiment j'adore
j'adorais déjà avant avec le jazz 5 et
là que jacques 6h à mon avis ça va
envoyer du bois alors ici autofocus à
l'autofocus à détection phase c'est un
peu différent de ce que nous propose
sony mais de ce que je vois là il ya un
vrai suivi un vrai tracking ça c'est
bien vrai dire je voulais vous montrer
un truc par rapport à cette focus alors
désolé on est dans la rue à rome voyez
on est en train de filmer la en même
temps je vous montre tout directement en
fait là vous avez le sujet détectés soit
de l'humain soit le visage et les yeux
ou alors même un animal est un humain
donc ça c'est marrant donc si vous
voulez salut alliotte c'est mon fils si
vous voulez venir filmer un animal en
même temps et bien vous pouvez le faire
alors moi je me suis mis sur humains
parce que c'est tout ce dont j'ai besoin
mais vous avez également reconnaissance
du visage et des yeux ça c'est un peu ce
qu'on va retrouver chez chez sony et ça
je voudrais juste ça est pour l'instant
sain sommes en tout cas super bien en
tout cas très intéressant de l'avoir
proposé comme ça ici on est compatible
avec les accessoires de dj alors je vous
le dis un peu pêle mêle parce que je les
la halle dj iron a donc on pourrait le
mettre sur andy giles ronan sans aucun
problème contrôler à distance transfert
est mise à jour en wifi 5g pour peut
également se connecter en bluetooth
qu'est ce que j'ai à vous raconter
également lors une différence de poids
le gh5 fait 6 145 g on est un peu plus
long parce que la fabrication est un peu
différente on à 7 139 g c'est exactement
le même viseur que le jazz 5 marie c'est
l'idée c'est l'adn pas sont retrouvés
avec son gh5 et il sera dispo dans la
première quinzaine de mars 2022 le tarif
du boîtier c'est de 1199 euros en fait
c'est le tarif du jaj 5 plus l'option
vélo qui inclut directement ici dans le
danger h si vous avez des pré commandes
jusqu'au 30 avril prochain vous avez un
an garanties supplémentaires en plus des
deux ans déjà donc ça fera trois ans
garantis plus une carte cf express
offert ce qui est pas mal et puis vous
allez avoir un bundle un kit avec
l'optique la calade ou 62 8 4 plus le
boîtier vous serez à 2799 euros dont
vous voyez c'est super intéressant alors
j'aime bien l'idée de m'en trouver qu'un
panasonic comme ça la voyez de me
retrouver en ville d'hommes filmé avec
un petit micro 4/3 ça me ramène un peu à
ce que je faisais au début du jeu voyez
ça ce look and feel j'aime bien cette
ambiance je sais pas j'aime bien ce
boitier je trouve cool je trouvais déjà
très très cool avec le gh5 et l'algérie
c'est une feuille blog un peu plus loin
je n'aurais mais un poil plus léger mais
comme il est là ben voilà c'est un truc
qui me plaît donc je vais pas vous
montrer la partie photo c'est pas mon
job moi je me concentre vraiment à de la
vidéo je fais de la vidéo pour le web je
fais du youtube dont je vous montre mes
usages tels qu'ils sont j'aime beaucoup
ce boîtier une fois de plus je le dis je
le redis je testerai plus tard plus
longuement puis faisant part et
peut-être j'en sais rien peut-être plus
tard d'ailleurs dit moi ça vous
intéresse un banc commentaires merci à
panasonic de leur donner l'opportunité
de le tester en avant-première
directement comme sa fille de vous
emmener en balade aaron donc ce n'est
peut-être pas le plus beau temps qu'on
peut avoir c'est déjà très très cool et
on en profite aux valeurs dites moi ce
que vous en pensez dans les commentaires
ce qui pourrait vous tenter si vous
voulez avoir des tests je pense plus
poussées en termes de photos et bien je
vous invite à aller voir les chaînes de
mes potes je pense notamment à hôtel qui
va vous en parlait il ya mon poto
scénique au qatar qui vous en parlera ya
pas mal de monde qui vont vous empêche
encore ni moins d'une petite dizaine à
l'avoir eu en avant-première donc vous
pouvez aller jeter un petit coup d'oeil
chez eux si vous voulez des informations
complémentaires et puis quand à moi je
donne rendez vous très bientôt et on va
continuer on restera en filmera avec ce
j'agisse plus tard donc bien évidemment
rester connecté allez je vous embrasse à
bientôt pour les soins de lookout
[Musique]